your friend your good buddy your
Compadre Charlemagne the God you were
just you we mentioned him a little bit
earlier yes uh you were on his show The
Breakfast Club massive audience you know
massive black audience
um breaking news I just found out you're
black that's crazy I just found that out
yeah
what amazing respect but you were on
about two weeks ago and he did a
reaction video and he uh so politely
called you the Donkey of the Day and he
went Ham on you brother so you know he's
got a huge voice in the black community
obviously what do you say to him what do
you say to the black community that they
think you're the donkey when you're just
like look personal power personal
self-improved but accountability well he
called me the Donkey of the Day as I
recall because I didn't make the debate
stage and I complained about it and I I
was on his show saying that there's no
systemic racism in America and here
Larry is complaining about the systemic
way he did not make the debate stage
that's what he said make to me that made
no sense and frankly I believe he called
me the Donkey of the Day because if you
look at the comments and I have a friend
who read every single one of them and
these are his people 85 of them thought
he got his butt kicked yep yeah so would
you go back again oh absolutely in fact
okay I'm tentatively scheduled to go
back how do you win over not only
Charlemagne but the people who think
like Charlemagne because there's
millions of them tell the truth
yeah tell the truth but you know this
I've been doing this for 40 years what
you guys are doing been for 40 years and
I've noticed something when somebody
calls up and I always took pride in
taking people who disagree with me no
one in the middle of a conversation is
going to go you know what you're right
yeah yeah I I I've been in I've had any
Epiphany it's the person who's driving
who's listening that I'm talking to
and so I I know that Charlemagne the
guy's not gonna go you know Larry I
never thought about this and you're
right there is no systemic racism I need
to rethink my assumptions he's not going
to do that but his listeners will and if
you look look at the comments many of
them have not saying they suddenly
become card caring uh Trump supporting
Republicans but they're beginning to
rethink their assumptions they know
fatherlessness is a big bigger problem
than systemic racism they see the
schools they see the crime
one quick story go for it when I was in
high school there was a guy named
Gilbert and he was a iffy kind of
student he wasn't a bad student but he
wasn't somebody that was academically
oriented as I was
I told you my my dad used to have a cafe
and I like didn't like working for him
so when my dad and I stopped talking to
each other 15 years old I decided to get
me a job in the Summer with the with the
county L.A County you had to go downtown
and take this big test it must have been
three or four hundred people this is in
the in the late 60s most of the people
there were white
and one of the guys taking the test was
this guy named Gilbert from my high
school and I saw him and um
it was a three-hour exam uh math uh
reading comprehension stuff like that
and then you had to go out in the hall
and then they grade the paper you come
back in so I see Gilbert he goes hey
Larry what's up I said what's going on
Gilbert he said watch out they're going
to get us
who's going to get us he said the white
people how great in these exams yeah
I said they're going to get us he said
watch them flunkers so we go back in
about 300 people as I said they call out
your uh name if you are to remain
meaning you pass the test
and then it would give you a bunch of
options for jobs and if you didn't get
your name called you had to leave so I'm
sitting there calling off the names of
course my name was called
as were the names of a number of black
people
and then you hear a screeching of chairs
into people who weren't called get up to
leave
so Gilbert walks right by me and he says
as he sees me sitting there obviously my
name was one of those who was called who
was named
he said what did I tell you
how can somebody make an argument that
white people are going to flunk black
people I'm black I'm sitting there I'm
not flunked and he walks by me and he
says what did I tell you
this is the mentality this is a sick
this is an illness and a lot of black
people have that we have to raise our
game I remember the Dream Team and the
Olympics
because we began losing matches we can't
stand college kids anymore and expect to
win 92. so the Dream Team crushes
everybody
well now we still send the best we don't
crush people anymore
it's competitive now because the rest of
the world raised their game they didn't
lower the hoop they didn't widen the
hoop they raised we need to raise our
game as black people if you look at a
graph of how much homework a black kid
does every night versus a white kid
versus Asian kid it's like this
if you don't put in the time
you're not gonna get the results we have
to stop bitching and moaning and whining
about systemic racism and raise our
effing game that's what I'm all about so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]